now to Ron DeSantis showing up on Gavin
newsom's Turf the Florida governor
taking to the Streets of San Francisco
and bringing attention to the DK of a
once Great American city
we saw people defecating on the street
we saw people using heroin we saw people
smoking crack cocaine the city is not
vibrant anymore it's really collapsed
because of leftist policies San Fran's
Democratic mayor not taking his crap and
hitting back
unfortunately in politics the old
Playbook of focusing on the negative and
targeting places like San Francisco have
been unfortunately the norm so we need
to turn that around I don't know what
his experience was you know people are
taking what they're seeing in videos and
seeing in terms of a snapshot and
elevating them but the people who
actually live in the tenderloin have
businesses in the tenderloin who are
experiencing that those are the people
we should actually be listening to wow
uh those are the people who have been
talking the most about the decline in
San Francisco Jesse I understand it it's
it's personal to her she's the mayor
behind what we and overseeing a dramatic
change in this city but shouldn't she
kind of welcome the attention that she's
getting as well it might actually Force
the entire city to do something I'd be
humiliated if I were her I've probably
on Jesse Waters Prime Time talk to more
people in the tenderloin than she has if
she talks to them she might know that
there's a problem this city is such a
political gift for the Republican party
you have a location where all of the
people running for president can go to
and it's just a pile of every failure
the Democrats have had crime illegals
drugs homelessness that the Republican
candidate can just point to and say see
this is what Democrats give you this is
Joe Biden this has given us the ability
to link San Francisco to Joe Biden I
mean you'd rather pay what a million
dollars to a political consultant to run
a 30-second ad you could also just spend
500 on a plane ticket to San Francisco
and take out your iPhone and get more
traction than that RFK is getting
traction DeSantis is getting traction
now permission to make an analogy
absolutely imagine if January 6th was a
city yes January Philadelphia
and the Democrats could just fly in
there and just put up a Podium and then
in the background there was a bunch of
people wearing red hats climbing all
over the Capitol and say see this is
what Republicans do it's the same exact
thing airtight analogy but what you're
pointing out is there is no Republican
City you could point to so years so you
had to make up an analogy exactly
because it doesn't exist which is why if
I were Biden I'd be mad and I would call
breed I'd say breed you're killing me
lady clean it up they're linking I live
in Delaware they're making me out to be
the doc Dr tenderloin over here here I
need a little help and your career is
going to go nowhere if you don't fix
this mess that's what I would do um what
do you think Sandra comment about
defecating it gets to me because this
has recently happened to me here in New
York City where you were defecating no
but I saw it but I saw someone
defecating and by the way it was like
three within three feet of a police car
wow um and it changes you it it it it's
just it's awful it's really awful to see
and I feel a feel for these uh folks who
have tried to hang on and and live in a
city that they love but that's not the
case so much anymore in this two-week
arrest period the 45 arrest only three
people were from San Francisco these
people who are committing these crimes
aren't even from there first of all and
now just to go shopping you're gonna
have to walk through metal detectors I
mean what is happening and then once you
get through the metal detector they're
shutting off the second exit God forbid
there's a fire
um and then you get there and you have
to go find an employee to open up the
the lock store shelf to get your
toothpaste I mean it's a mess and why is
anybody going to want to live in what is
usually the conveniences of downtown
living if you don't have those things
anymore so in 2021 and 2022 29 1000
people officially change their their
licenses from California to Florida
people vote with their feet I think I'm
stealing that line from Ron DeSantis
because that is what is happening there
and it's only getting worse there's no
sign that anybody's waking up to just
how bad it's getting you know uh judge
Sandra brings up a good point a lot of
these people aren't from there and I
think the stat is one third of the
homeless population of America resides
in one state and that's California so
what does that tell you that they are
choosing to come there well it tells me
that when the mayor of San Francisco
London breeds says you know don't just
take a snapshot talk to the people
you're the one who created the
atmosphere that is drawing the people to
the tenderloin District you're the one
mayor breed and you she's so she's so
opposed to people talking about the
truth she's the one who opened the
notorious open-air drug Market in 2022
that they're now closing that cost 18
million dollars because they thought it
was a good idea just like she thought it
was a good idea to defund the police and
now of course she's changed her mind I
think these people are stupid I mean
they're either they either openly want
chaos and Anarchy or they really are
dumb enough to think they've got the
answer but time makes it clear that they
don't have the answers and this whole
thing it isn't it isn't just about a
breed mayor breed London breed it's
about the left versus the right we're
going to have fentanyl available for you
so of the 45 arrests uh 42 of the people
who arrested for fentanyl are from out
of the state because they want to come
in to buy fentanyl they know that
California is a place to do it and a
half a million people in the last two
years have left California I mean that's
a lot of people in the last two years it
tells you that it's a hell hole and they
don't want to admit it they don't want
you talking about it we talked about
this yesterday with ABC where they said
it was too dangerous four in the morning
to videotape it is dangerous because the
leaders there are not doing anything
about it Jessica I go back to this
amazing point that was made surprisingly
by Jesse which is that ah you it's easy
to do this to the left because the
cities are the product of their ideas
and so you can see the homelessness the
devastation the defecation but you can't
do that with a republican City that must
be very embarrassing to you as a
Democrat how humiliated are you right
now
you're actually feeling pretty good
um because I have a city to talk about
and a city in Ronda Santa says home
state okay a city called Jacksonville
could also refer to it as the murder
capital could also refer to it as place
where there was a Republican mayor until
Donna Deegan just about a month and a
half ago was able to turn that seat
should a Democrat TV personality who is
now the mayor same thing as what
happened in Colorado Springs Colorado
flipping long-held Republican seat Ronda
Santos helps himself in doing this
obviously this is for his supporters or
potential supporters but he ignores the
fact that Florida has the third highest
homeless population in the country
behind California which also has a
population double the size
of Florida and behind New York and we
live here we know that there are a lot
of homeless people here but he has the
number three highest homeless population
he's not talking about that he's not
talking about the homicide rate in a
city like Jacksonville and what his plan
is to fix his home state he's only only
pointing figure fingers at what's going
on in quote liberal states so we'll see
I hope Donna Deegan can turn things
around in Jacksonville but these
Republicans when we look at what they're
doing as Democrats we say there are
things that you need to get your house
in order about and we talked about
Bakersfield as well where Kevin McCarthy
is from complete Republican control and
much more dangerous than a Chicago or
New York everyone has selective outrage
for whatever but there's a lot of
homeless tent cities where everyone's
defecating and shooting have you seen
him before well show me the video at
Mar-A-Lago maybe not but if you go
outside I have not seen on our air ever
a homeless encampment
crazy on drugs in this state of Florida
odds are
if it has the third highest homeless
population in the country and it has
good weather that there are people
living outside impounding people in
hammocks you're not counting real
homeless
I will take this as an utter victory
that he has gone to all these people
it it
I think I have not seen it you have
anyone homeless in Florida well someone
in the control room please find one
because they're definitely out there
passed out 10 people on the beaches
homeless
temporarily unconscious I'm embarrassed
for you all right you'd make that two of
us
all right hey Sean Hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else